ARE.
>> Juan: ONCE AGAIN UNDER FIRE.
HEALTH EXPERT NOT SAYING THIS
ABOUT OUTDOOR COVID
TRANSMISSIONS AND MASK
GUIDELINES.
>> IT'S PRETTY COMMON SENSE NOW
THAT OUTDOOR RISKS IS REALLY
REALLY QUITE LOW, PARTICULARLY,
I MEAN, IF YOU WERE A VACCINATED
PERSON, WEARING A MASK OUTDOORS,
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY THE RISK IS
MINUSCULE.
>> Juan: REPORTS SAY UPDATED
GUIDANCE ON WEARING MASKS
OUTDOORS FROM THE CDC COULD
ARRIVE AS EARLY AS TOMORROW.
NOW, THAT COMES AS A NEW STUDY
SUGGESTS OUR SOCIAL DISTANCING
RULES MAY HAVE BEEN MISGUIDED
FROM THE VERY START.
THAT STUDY CLAIMS THAT STANDING
APART AT 60 FEET IS NO SAFER
THAN AT 6 FEET.
AND THAT EXPOSURE TIME INDOORS
IS ACTUALLY FAR MORE IMPORTANT.
JESSE, THE CDC CHANGES
GUIDELINES AS THEY GET NEW
INFORMATION, WE'RE NOW MORE THAN
A YEAR INTO THIS PANDEMIC,
SITUATIONS CHANGE.
SO, ISN'T THAT TREASON CELEBRATE
THAT THEY ARE BEING HONEST AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD?
>> Jesse: YEAH, LIKE THREE
MONTHS LATE, JUAN.
I WAS LISTENING TO HOWARD STERN
THIS MORNING, HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT HOW HE GOES OUTSIDE WITH
HIS WIFE BETH AND THEY GO ON
WALKS AND HE WEARS A MASK AND
HIS WIFE BETH DOESN'T.
HE HAD ON DR.  -- CHIEF MEDICAL
CORRESPONDENT FOR CBS NEWS.
DOCTOR, WHO IS RIGHT IN THE
DOCTOR SAYS THERE IS TWO ANSWERS
THERE IS THE PERSONAL ANSWER,
AND THEN THERE IS THE PUBLIC
POLICY HEALTH ANSWER.
PERSONAL ANSWER, SURE, YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WEAR A MASK WHEN YOU ARE
VACCINATED AND GO OUTSIDE.
BUT THE ANSWER FROM A PUBLIC
POLICY HEALTH PERSPECTIVE IS WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WEAR MASKS,
THE MESSAGE IS WHEN YOU WEAR
OUTSIDE YOU WEAR A MASK, AND
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
TELLING THE TRUTH AND MESSAGING.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T
WANT MESSAGING ANYMORE.
WE CAN GO ONLINE AND WE CAN SEE
THE STATISTICS.
WE SEE THE NUMBERS.
WE SEE THE TRENDS.
WE HAVE ALL THE STUDIES.
IT'S NOT LIKE 20 YEARS AGO
WHETHER YOU HAVE TO MESSAGE US
TO DEATH ABOUT A WAR OR, YOU
KNOW, A PANDEMIC OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT.
WE GET IT LIKE FAUCI IS ON THERE
THE OTHER DAY, YESTERDAY, SAYING
THERE IS 60,000 NEW INFECTIONS A
DAY.
I SAID THAT SOUNDS HIGH.
I CHECKED IT OUT.
WE ARE AT 232,000 NE 23 -- 32,0W
INFECTIONS A DAY.
IS HE B.S.ING US.
WE JUST WANT THE TRUTH
DR. FAUCI.
>> Juan: DAY BEGAN, WE ARE
SEEING A SURGE IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND ESPECIALLY THIS
IS A SURPRISE AMONG ME PEOPLE
30, 40, 50, HIGHER RATES OF
INFECTIONS FOR THEM.
WHAT ARE WE TO THINK ABOUT AT
THIS MOMENT IN DEALING WITH THE
VIRUS?
>> IF YOU HAVE BEEN VACCINATED
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WEAR A MASK
OUTSIDE PERIOD.
I HAVE ANTIBODIES.
WHEN I GO OUTSIDE, I DON'T WEAR
A MASK.
IF THE CDC COMES OUT AND SAYS
HEY YOU HAVE BEEN VACCINATED
DON'T WEAR A MASK OUTSIDE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT THEY
WILL HAVE DELIVERED TANGIBLE
BENEFITS TO PEOPLE AND IT COULD
GET PEOPLE TO GO AND GET
VACCINATED WHO ARE RETICENT TO
GO AND GET THE SHOT WHAT IT 22%
PERCENT SAID IN THE FOX NEWS
POLL THEY DON'T PLAN TO GET IT
IN TERMS OF MESSAGING I WAS
SITTING IN THE LOBBY OF MY
BUILDING TWO DAYS AGO SOME DUDE
WALKING OUT AND WAS SHOCKED HE
DIDN'T HAVE A MASK ON.
I WENT YOU HAVE BEEN VACCINATED
YOU DON'T NEED A MASK OUTSIDE.
HE LOOKED AT ME LIKE I FLASHED
HIM.
AND FLASHED HIM A REPTILIAN
UNDERCARRIAGE.
GOT.
>> Greg: NICE.
>> Greg: I'M JUST THINKING ABOUT
THAT WHAT AN IMAGE, DAGEN.
LOOKING TO FAUCI FOR LEADERSHIP
IS LIKE LOOKING TO "THE VIEW"
FOR BRAIN CELLS.
THAT'S NOT HIS ROLE.
AND HE IS JUST THERE TO JUST
SPOUT WHATEVER HE HAS TO SAY.
FOR EXAMPLE, THEY SAY NOW THAT
WHAT 660 FEET AWAY IS NO SAFER
THAN 6 FEET.
I ANTICIPATE THE MEDIA SAYING
OKAY, WE WE SHOULD STAY 61 FEET
APART JUST FOR THE SUMMER.
61 FEET APART.
I WILL DO IT, TOO.
I WILL DO IT.
DAGEN, I LOVE WALKING AROUND
WITHOUT MY MASK ON.
I CAN'T TELL IF THE PEOPLE ARE
REACTING WITH THE PASSING SCOWL
BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE ME.
[LAUGHTER]
OR BECAUSE I'M MASKLESS.
>> Juan: SO, DANA, THEY ARE
SAYING SHORTLY THERE WILL BE
MORE VACCINE THAN PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO GET THE VACCINATION.
SHOULDN'T PEOPLE JUST GET
VACCINATED?
>> Dana: LOOK, IT IS A PERSONAL
CHOICE BUT I THINK THAT DOES
PROVIDE YOU A LOT OF FREEDOM AND
CONFIDENCE.
I WALKED AROUND ALL DAY OUTSIDE
IN NEW YORK CITY ON SATURDAY.
I DIDN'T WEAR A MASK.
I DIDN'T GET ONE SCOWL OR ONE
NEGATIVE COMMENT BECAUSE I THINK
PEOPLE ARE REALIZING THAT IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE ANYMORE.
I THINK THE CDC DO THIS ABOUT
MASKING OUTSIDE AND THEY HAVE
HELD THE ANNOUNCEMENT TO GIVE IT
TO PRESIDENT BIDEN SO THAT HE
COULD DO IT ON HIS FIRST 100
DAYS HE SAID ON JANUARY 21st
I'M JUST GOING TO ASK YOU TO DO
IT FOR 9 DAYS GUYS, SO TOMORROW
AT 1: 0 WATCH.
IS HE GOING TO MAKE THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT.
LAST THING I WOULD SAY THERE IS
NO RULE THAT YOU HAVE TO DO
EVERY SUNDAY SHOW EVERY WEEK.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO IT
DR. FAUCI.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
TAKE A D